merci madame la parole est à monsieur
thierry mariani la question s'adresse à
monsieur le prix ministre puisque noël
approche max thion sera donc consensuel
mais je vous rassure tout de suite ce ne
sera pas une habitude et et monsieur le
ministre
j'espère vous serez y apporter une
réponse qui peut être saluée par
l'ensemble des bancs de cet hémicycle
parce que je pense que sainte ça peut
intéresser l'ensemble des banques cet
hémicycle dans la plupart des pays
les campagnes électorales sont des temps
fort de mobilisation et impliquent des
moments de partage des valeurs
nationales des symboles nationaux et
notamment des couleurs nationales ainsi
par exemple en allemagne aux états unis
en russie en espagne en italie
ces campagnes électorales sont
l'occasion de mettre en avant les
couleurs nationales
le paradoxe est qu en france
l'utilisation de ces couleurs nationales
pendant les campagnes électorales est
interdit c'est interdit comme voulu ce
comme chacun de nous le sait dans cet
hémicycle sur l'ensemble des documents
officiels et pourquoi parce que un
article r 27 codifié dans un décret de
1964 interdit tout simplement
l'utilisation des couleurs bleu blanc
rouge dans les documents de campagne
pour éviter toute confusion avec les
documents officiels il est vrai qu'à
l'époque lou rtl viennent d'être lancés
et la télé couleur n'arrivera que trois
ans après donc en réalité
ma question est toute simple j'ai une
réforme vous proposez qui peut rendre
des couleurs à la france dans cette
période qui s'approche où nous aurons
des présidentielles et des élections
législatives et qui coûtera rien comme
le souligne mon collègue alain marsaud
et bien tout simplement monsieur le
premier ministre
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à abolir cet
article r 27 du décret de 1964 qui
permettrait à ce que pour nos élections
présidentielles pour nos élections
législatives
les trois couleurs nationales puissent
être à nouveau être mis à l'honneur
comme c'est le cas dans toutes les
grandes démocraties et je pense que
c'est une réforme qui pourraient tous
nous rassembler la parole est à monsieur
andré vallini secrétaire d'état chargé
des relations avec le parlement
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député mariani l'article r 27 du code
électoral vous l'avez dit dispose que
les affiches et circulaires ayant un but
ont un caractère électoral qui
comprennent une combinaison des trois
couleurs blanc bleu blanc et rouge à
l'exception de la reproduction de
l'emblème d'un parti ou d'un groupement
politique sont interdites
cette interdiction est limité aux
affiches et circulaires et n'interdit en
aucune manière en aucune manière la
reproduction de l'emblème d'un parti
politique qui lui peut comporter trois
couleurs elle vise à éviter les
confusions qui pourraient l'être chez
les électeurs sur l'éventuel caractère
officiel d'une candidature arborant les
couleurs tricolores caractère officiel
d'une candidature qui rappellerait celle
du second empire elle poursuit donc un
objectif de sincérité du scrutin
l'inobservation de cette disposition
peut être sauver leur dire qu'on suppose
électorale vous le savez dans ce cas le
juge examine au cas par cas si cet
affichage a été naturalisé la sincérité
du scrutin
le juge prend en considération le
caractère massif au nom de l'affichage
mais aussi l'écart de voix entre les
candidats ou les listes de candidats la
jurisprudence a ainsi reconnu par
exemple que les affiches électorales
polychrome qu'ils utilisent et d'autres
teintes et couleurs bleu blanc et rouge
n'était pas interdite
pour toutes ces raisons et parce que la
jurisprudence le permet le gouvernement
n'entend pas abroger cette disposition
monsieur le député la séance des
questions au gouvernement